go sit another table
inflation affects the way zerlina smith
members eats shops drives nearly every
aspect of her life we went from lipton's
to
a store brand t because i love it my
daughter loves it and that's what we
could afford
the inflation has us in the store where
we used to can spend say
20 bucks on lunch meat bread and
cheese the basic things have double
loaf of bread is five dollars who can
afford that
food and fuel have been especially hard
hit pandemic-related kinks in the global
supply chain and an energy shortage
partly due to the war in ukraine have
driven up prices on a broad range of
goods if you do see products on sale
which has become less pervasive than
ever before you know buy it stock up
put things in the freezer because prices
are not going to go down that's left
grocery store shelves more bare and more
pricey the dollar tree is the kind of
store a lot of working-class families
come to to save money for 35 years
nearly everything in the store cost a
dollar now
it's a buck and a quarter question
the founder of chicago's non-profit
violence interrupters program says
inflation appears to be contributing
also to a spike in crime the reason why
some of the crime levels are rising is
because inflation is pretty tough out
here you have people out there trying to
rob peter to pay paul you have the
carjackings on the rise with the u.s
government hoping to lower gas prices by
releasing oil from the nation's
strategic petroleum reserve and the
federal reserve raising interest rates
to discourage borrowing president biden
says his administration is working on it
more and more americans get jobs as they
do it's going to help ease the supply
pressures we've seen
and that's good news for fighting
inflation it's good news for our economy
and it means that our economy has gone
from being on the mend to being on the
move
for zerlina smith members inflation has
also dashed her hopes of starting off
the year with a new kitchen laborer
prices went up from twelve thousand
dollars to twenty five thousand dollars
in a matter of a year so this is the old
kitchen with new appliances
and we have cabinets in my garage we
have countertops in my garage flooring
and we can't afford to do it
for her and many americans each day
brings less and less for them to cut
john hendren al jazeera chicago